here's some breaking news to tell you  about some good news as regards the  coronavirus  vaccine rollout a tweet just in from the  health  secretary to say we have now vaccinated  half of all adults in the uk  now the vaccine and national success  story according to  matt hancock and our way out of this  pandemic when you get the call get the  job so that is  quoting the health secretary who says  yesterday we vaccinated more people than  any day yet that was uh approaching 50  wasn't it 49.9  of the adult population in the uk have  been vaccinated well that 50 percent  figure  has now been passed half of all adults  in the  uk the flag of the united kingdom uh  image  there to remind you in fact uh the uk  administered  yesterday a record number of daily  covert doses 660  000 plus that was a total of first and  second jabs 26.3 million or so  people vaccinated now so half the uk  adult population has had a job